you've talked to people that uh
told stories of ufo encounters
what is the most fascinating to you
about the stories of these ufo
encounters that uh that you've heard
that people have told you the similarity
of them uh
the uniformity of the of the stories now
i just want to say up front
a lot of people
think that when i speculate
i believe something that's not true
right speculation is just creativity
speculation is the beginning of
hypothesis
none of what i hear in terms of the
anecdotes do i necessarily believe are
they true but i still find them
fascinating to listen to because at some
level they're still raw data
and you have to listen and once you
start to hear
the same story again and again
then you have to say well there might be
something to it i mean maybe it's some
kind of a jungian
uh background in the human mind and
human consciousness that creates these
stories again and again as coming out of
the dna it's coming out of that
pre-programmed something and young
talked quite a bit about this kind of
thing uh the collective unconscious
but actually one of the most interesting
ones i find is this constant
uh message
that
you're not taking care of your world
and this
came long before
climate change it came long before
uh many kinds of you know let's say
current day memes
uh around uh
you know taking care of our planet uh
pollution etc
and so you know for instance perhaps the
best example of this the one that i find
the most fascinating is a story out of
zimbabwe uh 50 or 60 children
one afternoon
in
zimbabwe it's a it was a well-educated
group of white and black children
uh who and lunchtime and the playground
saw a craft
uh and they saw little men
and they all ran into the teachers and
they told the same story and they drew
the same pictures
and the message several of them got was
you are not taking care of your planet
and they've got you know there's
actually a movie coming out uh on this
uh episode and
30 years later now
the people who are there the children
who've now grown up
say it it happened to us now did it
happen
was it some sort of hallucination or was
it a an imposed hallucination by
something was it material i i don't know
but
these kids were seven to ten years old
you see them on video
seven to ten year olds can't lie like
that
and so
you know whether it's real or not i
don't know but i find that fascinating
data and again it's the it's these
unconnected stories
of individuals with the same
with the same story
that is
worthy of
further inquiry
yeah so here we are humans with limited
cognitive capacities trying to make
sense of the world trying to understand
what is real and not
we have this dna that somehow in complex
ways is interacting with the environment
and then we get these uh
novel
ideas
that come from
the populace
and then
they make us wonder about what it all
means
and so how to interpret it if you think
from an alien perspective how would you
communicate
with other lifelike organisms
you perhaps have to
find
in points on this interaction between
the the dna and its
manifestations in terms of the the the
human mind and the
how it interacts with the environment so
get some kind of all right what is this
dna what does this environment have to
get in somehow right to like interact
with it to get to perturb the system to
where these little ants human like ants
get like excited and figure and see
stuff out yeah yes and then and then
somehow steer them
uh first of all for investigative
purposes understand like
oftentimes to understand the system you
have to perturb it exactly yeah it's
like poke at it they get they get
excited or not and then the the
the other ways you want to
if you worry about them you can steer in
one direction or another and this kind
of idea of that we're not taking care of
our world
um
that's interesting i mean that's
comforting that's hopeful because that
means
the greater intelligence which is what i
would hope would want to take care of us
like we want to take care of the
guerrillas in the national parks in
africa yeah but we don't want to take
care of cockroaches so there's a line we
draw so you have to hope that
right now we're a bunch of angry monkeys
and you know maybe whatever these
intelligences are
are also keeping an eye on us
you know that you don't want a bunch of
you know you don't want the angry monkey
troop
stomping around the local galactic arm
do you think these folks are telling the
truth
do you think they saw
what they say they saw
i think they
saw what they said they saw but i also
think they saw what they were shown
i mean if you go back to the
whole notion of
okay how long has this
been around it didn't just start showing
up in 1947. right there are stories
going back
uh you know into the 1800s
of people who saw things in their
farming in their farm fields in the u.s
it's it's in
it's in
local newspapers from the 1800s it's
fascinating
but if you can go even further back
you know so to your point of how are how
would you as a higher intelligence
represent yourself
to a lesser intelligence
well let's go back to
pre-civilization
maybe you show yourself as the spirits
in the forest
and you give messages
through that
once you get a little bit more civilized
civilized then you show yourself as the
gods
and then you're god well we don't
believe in god anymore necessarily not
everybody does so what do we believe in
we believe in technology so you show
yourself as a form of technology
right but the common thread is
you're not
alone and there's something else here
with you
and there's something that's as you said
watching you and at least
watching over your shoulder
but i i think that like any good parent
you don't
tell your student everything
you make them learn
and learning requires mistakes because
if you tell them everything then they
get lazy
you